As salaamu alaykum
Alhamdulillah.
Good on this.
Even another one
We're Zainup?
Zainab, without holding meetings, so
Oh, mana
I have a meeting daun fruit hakten standard
validated.
Ashan,
I didn't have some advice on it
Okay, another more ditch
Hello, hello
Hello and Adam Lee.
Number…
From below.
Alhamdulillah.
Yeah, very tough
All time.
.
Yeah, I goat for vacuum haga, masagin aya haga.
Integrana.
And as I pull
Zainabhad
I'll, in the survey, I will say 11,000
Um…
The survey?
One of my social media
Yes, and I'm activating my camera.
Come in.
Been up.
Mr. Survey Shabem
Okay ma'am.
Therefore.
Our Vatican chemist hegel.
Ms.
internship this day?
Shaka negative one bank
And they create solution.
Our compute requirements and the nice info savva Kaza Department.
But then an internship.
So how would I configure the solution?
As much as retcon-based solution
Sprints.
Inspired by sprints.
Hmm.
Hemp.
problem statement of denal
Sprints virtual internship generation.
Hagerfield Business Betana.
Mesh.
For the survey.
Channel Projection
It'll, Agent
Validation, our data
My word system.
Okay.
Meeting pipeline
I had been home
Almost approved with any
For final reason
Deal, register it in solution.
Okay, then ma'am.
And I'm the, uh…
Antika's early allocable solution.
But bets are the solution die applicable.
Exhibited is.
Okay, and I assess out of here.
And already, another two solutions, thanks, I can do
Okay.
Our solution has a prototype.
I can't have August even on
Buzzard.
Proclaimed.
For when I'm not a Daism are applicable.
Yeah, yeah, he's a very.
Your initial resources, and a few restrictions Mayan
They didn't decide yet.
And if you will have present
The sky is our limit.
Technical feasibility
Hmm.
design without restrictions
rough estimate.
Around Tech World development
Alhamdulillah.
So then we can either go unsight
Rafi, I mean almost
Okay, it makes sense. Bardu beta team.
Can have an internship with it.
extended the internship day.
the famine of the E.
My hand fick it up to prioritization.
little user demonst…
Backlog roadmap die kundfie hagat pror ochter.
team have experienced
Zoom behind.
Bosito, with Zoom again.
I say, time.
And then I just see if there are teams in the.
Bardune solution.
iDemon can provide you with demod.
the.
Within Amazon percentage.
100% accurate.
Absolutely
The neither of solution masalan.
Our solution, Dali user stories.
Very feasible for the lawyer
Solution-oriented mission, technical feasibility and we can also conflict software. And dating.
And then experience
without… feedback.
When I check Alijo or
Estimation.
And after the…
Okay, tell me.
And, if you confirm zero.
If hefa, Ibn who?
El Torio.
I mean, teramos que na ciro marco accurate numbers
Edit.
If that was a master sheet
Master Freet
Nice.
And then we can
No, he's in there.
Make sure round one, can it feel active learner?
Round two team round three expected samar vein
Phil group options
El problems in Afsar, or diversify.
Ashen.
profit can feed 3 teams with us for the variety of Ottomania.
fully stack
business development.
I mean around
And the elementary meetings.
And the feature in Islet Grido will feature a board of title Meeting Scheduling
automatic.
Amazon Auto 40nd, hinder.
For the more of the future out of knowledge.
Mileage level.
And then through that.
Well, you know, agent Elementor
Fasora, tikalimku, into tahdiden will persona tato, kuch tennimasaran men.
Fair him into Minen Venturubital Mentor Bkend law.
Oh, feedback, but I was
Okay.
mental task.
Bernardo, an agent bust.
Oh, and feedback, delivery method.
I.
And let me
Where?
feedback.
In my second video.
And Norman, kung fu normal and one files.
How only can we all remodeling it.
And I'm about to also know.
Oh, my older
much.
Where we already handled
Technically, the maximum 10 minutes.
10 minutes. One-time technical error.
And then system auf Hegelfield back
onetime technical error
Okay.
Uh, one can.
eh.
Unless in the abruptly
So no error somehow
But also.
Okay, no.
Enormous.
Not much.
And no, um, for shekel.
product manager.
Rodos Emerson, but after that.
Oh, nice.
Mm.
What is that I'm scheduled for?
and feedback.
Phil is an intern a hemisphere.
Doctor.
And food.
3.
And even said.
feedback.
Again, the negative mineral fatin.
Okay. Feedback, bibafi magmani metriciskemon.
I mean
I will hang
Clarity, task management
We'll program structure circles experience the parameter the parameter. Communication mapping team of Sprints
Will AI agents, even Dr. Learner B5 Parameters
Sorry.
For how we adapt the baron ding kayaan, del humerifa awful meeting.
feedback.
The lesions for communication or cognition, we mentorship
full circle's experience, will task management and the clarity
task management and clarity.
Any ill feedback that I have.
Oh, I couldn't even know that.
I don't know if you have
Can we
And
And so far.
Issue, issue improvement
I will qualify the important skeleton.
Then if he had to use it.
Yeah, I feel less of them, notifications.
Hmm.
A good day.
Mish, and haga.
I see
movement and Paolo San Busil
Classification of mesh
overlapping
to the point with clear steps.
agents should be
Doctor Hagetmais elk.
synapti feedback
General
And an Agenticia.
Task description is hard to be understood
And the needs of human intervention
So the wild and feedback.
We can scroll around, Damal Tuha.
I mean…
I mean, look up!
Thank you.
I would at all.
In fact, an AI isn't as well.
However beautiful the old religion.
Then we have to score.
Hmm.
First, I would have to understand.
Um, tiny.
Again, Harfen
Fagi, how icon katabi
Right.
I guess there's one fit
But the team
numerical data, au
qualitative Data Camla, Tamilubi hamma saland dashboard.
Hi everyone.
time
Most.
Awesome.
Oh
But.
com.
Yeah, I need that
Validation with academic.
Thank you.
And the whole inside.
human mentors.
On the local aspect
Any intellectual
What is someone who
K.
requirements, tasks and hourly sprints.
Well, ah, focalera Yani.
For our OLL internship.
I'm also good
project requirement.
Hmm.
document fill our calls.
And Amazon?
Udi.
Well, indeed.
My roadmap, first principles.
to consideration.
our dilma fruit
Overview of Inside Kedemical PRD.
But the actual task.
will input smokers
I'll add them.
A loser that.
Okay.
uh.
With any is broadweller.
Muslim.
Technically.
Okay, and the data set feedback.
As I release notes, Kantari infected release notes
And they
If you file.
The retro deal, deal feedbacks
Release Notes to a document.
In the future is a little more sure
For the…
And then I could have it.
Andy
So, I mean…
It's over 500 choker round.
thermal fluidine.
Yeah, yeah, well, what behind the question
Oh, my little videos
So any, um…
I will allow us to the…
Biwa Guinea, be.
Besideshu…
And I have a lakhunturo Agbar.
features, Tanya.
Other chemical.
Pakmani?
I mean…
Okay, one minute.
Feed that you cannot.
Canti fintice.
Uh, Anna?
The highway also.
Authentic.
Okay.
Okie-doo.
Hmm.
Steps built up.
tariffs.
Datal track.
Hmm.
landing page.
Hello, I'm headed in marketing.
through different marketing.
landing page if you have northern Turtu
Hmm.
Okay, Tamayan.
Correct.
Okay.
And we only… our biological English when I'm chef.
I have set up an AI mentor.
Oh, Alice, and who, mainly your technical questions
We email greeting latest code
Any… til human will
November suit claim.
Well, that another validation
We love my granny
greeting system.
We scored the macerfitre tracks
Hoy el grid.
Bye.
Hey, doctor.
Listen, listen.
an AI agentu.
As Rao Avda
We know, prompting.
Hello, Masan, you manage meetings, he was at Oscort, he had problems.
Consistency. Father canister
mentors human.
will.
Command feedback and emotional AI feedback.
Humans?
Kibira?
Okay. Thank you.
Valentine's knowledge transfer.
knowledge transfer being a diploma courses
Alhamdulillah, finas minum tale.
Sorry.
I want another flowy YAML guidance, we roadmap, we use a botlock
Scott, we handle
out of.
If, uh, Pfizer out of a manager talk, did they.
No, no, no.
I've been annoyed.
Technology.
Was
Yeah, an equal
S.
Start moving
Hmm.
Communication with Sprints team, the support team, Canada
El TOCs
And human mentors
We'll
numerical feedback.
have a truthful average cam and Learner B5 or Kamfilmeer.
In general, a leverage in general can
3.7. The general average, meaning two rounds
back in 3.7 out of 5
And then ultimately agents
4.5.
Okay.
Read online.
Cut with insurance people who have the right thing.
list of features
headed in all the way.
And a project manager and a group that allows autonomy microphone Group
And if you want
In this 3.7 day
I'm sorry for me.
And it can be a good seboro gut.
And forgotten support…
Okay.
Hmm.
I have the feature with Amaru Finigi, Rohat Hilda muskela
Feedback
Oh, .
And I'm sure everybody knocked
Yes, allow feedback.
Also, allow any follow-up.
La Hawa.
In human mentoring channel manager.
Hotel AI is a birth.
Uh, in Moldovi, an El Thai actor, we Sahel Mondor, we saw now.
We can bip a few terms. Our technical terms.
Mustang.
Eh?
Oh, Mr.
.
I'll type in detox.
Internship Hena.
But hasn't…
Uh, Uli.
I often feel to come.
Tabawa and AB testing guide.
machines will cycle data
Yeah, and I'm not testing
Okay, basaluchenne hegemen.
Not my…
And anyone can.
Had to feature my NL users.
We'll be able to fans.
Manhattia
I want to feature whom the software testing team
users given in the intro user
And to donate feedback by the software testing team.
Ma'am, assessment fella.
Model onboarding.
The managerial team is my bad actor.
Alright, an assessment deli and historic bido
Yanni
I get any tool
With the Adaptive Assessment will deliver accurate profiling and learners
Ashen Nedon
The more accurate the results
As long as any users
Kada can be highly matching or ultimo Harmony.
There are some recommendation
I struggle with internship
Sprinter.
We have adopted any
phadermo fruit hagas na
Aspiring junior full-time.
experience that I'm in my mentor.
So, panel feedback.
e.
I've had the experience.
I'm already sure
Nice.
Oh, Diket Mahuda.
uh…
Oh, my hole above.
And actually, we're getting the feedback on a trophy.
Unforgettable requirements
What the requirements.
I quit our legal internship.
On the nominal
I have the experience.
Hi guys, Defied.
Which is
to present.
internship.
I don't be as a human
Bautlu.
# um.
meetings.
requirements.
How can the individual…
And in matchmaking goal assessment that will be done so it's accurate
They didn't
Yeah, and India results
Yeah, and
Lana learning seldom slay.
Bye.
Doctor.
And you look for coincidence
and Abnamadishtariel Hagatafase.
is a chemical
Yeah, I mean, I can take it.
Ms.
Those are…
areas of improvement.
Alright.
But had fallen internship.
I will, uh, instruct the loyal junior felon.
M.
While latesta hatred.
Um, Venus Maliko.
Oh,
Simulation
Nice to have.
Let me…
Yeah, no, don't get a flash and
Oh,
Okay.
And, uh, total feedback, okay?
round one.
From the remnational aspect of feedback, or average feedback
Hmm.
Oh, uh, if you're smoking round 1, round 2, round 3, while the bus.
get applicable round 10.
Would you like in life hanging again
Definitely study experience
Okay.
delete us any feedback
Okay, thank you so much. Thank you, Alecular details and you cut.
Bye.
I cannot get a stand-up meeting.
Awesome.
E.
Another statin it, though.
No factor.
I am.
Uh, um.
Okay.
Orlena
And then I also…
And Hasab Sarah can feed OE anywhere.
As I've written.
I don't have my thermal field.
Hmm. Okay.
Put us into time okay I
Good look. The Bilbert has?
Tasco luo.
Pulutamemo leh.
And I'm responsibility and motivational calamity.
Dilouette.
Obas un solatas que legenda.
Uh, deadline download tool. Now, the echo istagen.
Uh, meeting Abdulasant.
Miss Ablavion.
Step by Step.
We're good luck hens.
?
MIQ, uh…
inshaAllah.
I mean…
Ryan. Roy.
Anne. Levoi.